so when you measure the distance from a
point to a line you want to measure the
shortest distance the perpendicular
distance otherwise if you try to measure
from a point to the line like this way
or this way over this way you know those
are all going to be different distances
there's only gonna be one shortest
distance from the point to the line and
that's going to be the perpendicular
distance so the way we're gonna do this
this is very similar to when we found
the perpendicular bisector okay and I
showed you about that in one of the
previous videos but what we did is you
know we drew a perpendicular and we by
second the segment we're gonna do
something similar here we're going to
find the perpendicular from the point of
the line so what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna rotate this a little bit here
and I'm gonna draw I'm gonna open the
compass okay and what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna draw two arcs okay and if you
want you can make this one continuous
arc okay or you can pick it up and you
can make it two separate arcs so you can
either go like that or you can just make
it one continuous arc okay so then what
I'm going to do is I'm going to use this
point of intersection and this point of
intersection to draw two more arcs so
I'm going to rotate the diagram a little
bit here so you can see it and I'm going
to use at this point I'm going to use
this point now you can change how open
the compass is at this point I'm just
gonna open it up a little bit a little
bit more okay and I'm gonna make an arc
like this I'm gonna go to the other
point of intersection here keeping that
same setting on the compass I'm gonna
make a second arc and then what we're
gonna do is we're gonna draw a line that
goes through this point and this point
so let's go ahead and do that
okay now you can see alright that this
is perpendicular it's a 90-degree angle
okay and if you look this is actually
going to be the perpendicular bisector
of this segment from here to here so
we're just drawing the perpendicular
from this point to this line but in
actuality this is bisecting this segment
from here to here so this is how you
find the shortest distance from a point
to a line using constructions go ahead
and review the video if you need to and
I'll see in the next video